what are CEOs in the technology industry
telling you right now net positive net
negative all right
look there's a lot of optimism when
you're out here in San Francisco and
you're dealing with this tech community
there's an awful lot of optimism and the
optimism comes from the fact that a lot
of these companies are having a really
significant impact on businesses
industries a lot of change a lot of
disruption and a lot of growth and so
this is certainly a place and a part of
the economy where there's really
significant growth and growth generally
leads to optimism and so when you're out
here sure there's a lot going on in the
world in different ways but as you're
talking to companies in the tech sector
because of the growth that's available
in that space you tend to get you know a
more optimistic view than you might in
certain other slices of the economy as
that growth perpetuates and they want
you to seize the opportunity to start
coming to the public markets everyone's
very hopeful with a snap IPO being lined
up some part may be in the first quarter
will the doors were open wide will we
see the rest of the tech community in
the private sector come to the public
markets while there's there's certainly
lots of capital available for companies
that are growing and obviously tech
companies growing there's good amount of
capital available a lot of that capital
is available privately away from the
public market last year certainly was a
historically low year in terms of IPO
activity and I'm a big believer that
these things kind of ebb and flow but
ultimately gravitate back to me so you
know we're hopeful and optimistic that
we're gonna see more IPO activity this
year but I think when you look at the
world that a lot of these companies
operate in if they're able to run their
businesses and they're able to grow and
they're able to access capital privately
and there aren't other pressures from
shareholders or venture capitalists you
know these companies are putting off the
opportunity to come to the public
markets longer and the reason they can
is because the capital for growth is
available privately so I would expect to
see more companies coming back to the
public markets then we saw last year but
I think that process is going to
continue to be you know a very
thoughtful methodical process for a lot
of these companies as they're growing as
you say urban flow we saw plenty of
consolidation in M&A perhaps while the
cash balances were heavy we might see
yet more cash come if we see money come
from abroad back into the United States
expection
consolidation M&A to be high for 2017
well M&A activity especially in the tech
space is pretty active right now in fact
we've been involved and I think 14 M&A
transactions in the TMT space since the
first of the year and that in that
six-week period I think that's more than
we've seen in a comparable six-week
period I think you'd have to go back to
the year 2000 or you know the late 90s
to see that kind of activity around TMT
related activity I think there are a
number of reasons why that's occurring
you know one of the things that's
definitely happening here is you've got
a number of very very large companies
that are growing very very quickly you
know Facebook last year grew over 50% on
the 28 billion dollar revenue base
Amazon grew I think twenty seven percent
on one hundred and thirty billion dollar
revenue base as those companies are
growing they're generating cash they're
generating market cap but they're also
taking away revenues in some way from
some other businesses they're disrupting
to some degree and that puts some of
these other businesses in a place where
they've got to think about their
strategic options more carefully so I
think broadly speaking we're going to
continue to see consolidation in the
tech space and you know I think
activities will continue activity levels
will continue to be high this year if
the environment stays you know the way
it is now I think it could be a
relatively good M&A year in the TMT
space